well welcome thank you that was a great
way to kick things off there it is
um for people who don't know you how did
you because did you kind of um
give us kind of a rundown on how you
kind of started to get your Buzz going
in the in the comedy scene was it the
Opie and Anthony show Opie and Anthony
was was definitely big for me I started
stand up in 2009 2010 okay and then you
know it's interesting like I went that
route of you know I got on Guy Code Guy
Code and girl code which was was big
like Big Show by the way Shoals was on
there as well Charlemagne bro Schultz
Charlemagne uh um Akash there's like so
many people that came from that yeah man
uh uh Aquafina like all these people
um came out of it Nicole buyer and
there's like literally if you look it's
like wow Lil Duvall you're like all
these people on Guy Code and girl code
and really nobody the biggest one was
Charlemagne Charlemagne and Duvall were
you know pretty pretty famous but of
course other than that
um nobody really had a career it was
like all our our starting off points
Pete Davidson so so it's like um um you
know we did that show and that listen
that definitely got us to a point got us
in the clubs got us know but it still
didn't get get you to like you still
weren't like we weren't none of us were
really selling tickets or or you know on
the road because that's really the
barometer of a comic you could be on
this TV show on that TV show do that but
can you sell tickets because selling
tickets is it's not only it's not only
to to other Comics but also just as a
world thing it's like there's no smoke
in mirrors with ticket sales there's a
lot of smoke and mirrors with television
you could be on a hit oh I got a CBS
show I got it this show no one gives a
[ __ ] about you but guess what nobody
knows who you are nobody's nobody cares
to purchase ticket but there's no
because because you could make you know
the New York Post or whomever could
write an article about anyone saying
that the next big whatever and it's like
it's [ __ ] if no one's at your shows
yeah that if the people come that's how
you know so the people really weren't
coming until really I started to do
podcasting and the internet and I had to
kind of fail uh in television to learn
that because I had a I had a I have my
daughter's seven now she was about six
months old at the time I had a a sitcom
with CBS a pilot film the whole thing
you know I met dull people like chance
palmitary from A Bronx Tale um he played
my father in the show Diane Guerrero
played my love interest from Orange is
the New Black and and a bunch of other
stuff and uh and then I thought I was
gonna be you know the next Ray Romano or
the CBS was telling me you're gonna be
this and that and then the show didn't
go just failed did not did not go spend
a year in my life put everything I had
into it was going back and forth to La
time away from my family and then you
know missed moments with my daughter's
life and I was like well but this will
be good we'll move to LA because I was
following this you know route of the
blueprint yeah Seinfeld nine right right
right Bill Cosby all these guys and um
and it didn't go and I said well [ __ ]
now I got a daughter A young daughter
you know that I have a life here I got I
got a girl I have a stepson I was like I
need to make money so I said I made a
deal with myself when it when it didn't
go I said um I said I'm not going to
allow myself ever again in my career to
not be in control I'm never gonna put my
fate of my career and my family someone
else's hands in someone else's hands the
only people I will give it to is the
audience is the fan so I said find a way
to give your put your career in the
hands of your fans and that's when I
turn to the internet and podcasting and
it's really it was going good going good
and then it's weird like that when the
pandemic happened you know a lot of
people kind of career life got put on
pause but that's when my career like got
to the next level yeah because everybody
the whole world just sitting in front of
computer same thing with Schultz Schultz
exploded in the pandemic definitely so
it's it's one of those things where I
still and I live by that now and now I
am going to do some some TV stuff but
it's all on my own terms I'm like yo I
don't want to go to La I don't want I
want to do a whole if I'm going to do TV
it's got to be out of New York because
now I have the the the power because
because my fans right because my career
is in the hands of my fans now my
tickets are sold now we add shows now
you know I have a podcast and a patreon
and everything is being controlled
through my way so now I can tell you
know now I can dictate my own terms
where a lot of times with TV you can't
they'll the corporate person will say
well you can't do this because uh you
know we they have all the bargaining
chips but now I can say well listen if
we don't do it my way no problem I don't
find another guy yeah it's and and it's
very respectful but it's like there's no
reason I need to do your show other I
have everything I'm only going to do
what I want to do that's a great
position to be in inline yeah I sit on
my couch or or or our studio very close
to my house say exactly what I want to
the fans that want to hear it they come
and buy tickets to my show and we have
happy little family and to be honest
with you and I'm fine with this it's
like even somebody like my mother would
be like oh why don't you want to do this
show at that show because even she
doesn't understand like I lose money
doing that so not only is it Freedom uh
you know comedically which is the most
important but financially it's like you
know I make way more money doing it my
way sitting on my couch being I don't
miss a I barely miss any events in my
daughter's life unless I'm on the road
because I'm like I don't I'm not gonna
go away and do things I don't there's
time is time is so much more valuable to
me than money it's the greatest currency
it is the greatest currency I don't need
you know I think about money in a diff
very diff now I got two kids three
daughters and a stepson so now I'm like
yo I I I just don't I flat like I just
turned down a movie yesterday that would
take me to La for six weeks and I'm like
it was with a comedy hero of mine
um you know the money was okay uh but I
was like it's just not worth it man I I
I'll do that I'll hopefully that
opportunity similar opportunity is there
20 years from now when I'm older and my
kids don't want to hang out with me
anyway you know they're in college and I
but right now at this time I don't want
to miss anything in their life so I'm
very focused on hey I'm only going to do
things that keep me close to home now
listen I I gotta you know when I go on
the road and yeah we got a tour you
gotta I got a tour but it's but it's
minimal time it's like I get a weekend I
get to a city Thursday I'm home Sunday
morning it's not like eight weeks away
I'll never do that you know um so yeah
so so I think that was the big big thing
that changed in my career was my mindset
of I will only put my career in the
hands of my fans I will not I will and I
also call even on the TV shows I do it's
like listen if you don't like the way
I'm I understand you can't say certain
words on television I get that but if
you're gonna
dumb down my comedy to a point that I'm
not happy not me anymore I'm off the
show you could sue me I mean I don't
care you know most people would take the
movie with their comedic hero
listen for me I just thought about it
right and I was just like can you say
who it is Kevin Hart no no no it's uh
Bill bear okay oh oh [ __ ] yeah and and
and and and and and and you know
it was one of those things where I was
like yo like I I is that worth six weeks
away from my kids is that worth missing
six track practices a birthday uh um you
know um uh is it worth uh uh three movie
Nights is it is it is it worth all that
and I was like you know we're not
struggling financially right now
anything we want and I and you know
what's great you know what's the best
part about all this too is I can have
say what I want right to my fans who
care have some Financial Freedom and
flexibility that my fans give me and the
best part is I also have my anonymity
when I walk down the street I get
noticed maybe two or three times but
it's a beautiful thing but but it's like
but even if I did do even if I said
something out of context on a tweet
right nobody no one's coming for you
care they'd be like oh what does he have
a [ __ ] podcast where he sits down
with TT Jerry and Chrissy cast They
Don't they'd be like this is not big
enough now if you get in a movie if you
get on a big taste now they have [ __ ] to
take from you now but if you don't give
them that then what do they have to take